hey what's up everybody it's animak here
for
anime outpour and today i will be diving
into the epic new developments
in the boku no hero story the newly
introduced villain who just
lured deku into a trap turned out to be
a former hero
who betrayed the hero society and if
that
wasn't enough she also has multiple
quirks
there is a lot to talk about so stay
tuned
if you enjoyed the book no here content
here on the channel and you want us to
keep it going you know what to do
leave a like and comment it only takes a
second but it actually helps a lot
and if you're new to anime uproar or
maybe you watch us but you haven't
subscribed yet
make this the video that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on
all notifications finally this video
will contain boku no hero manga spoilers
so please proceed with caution you have
been warned
okay so in previous videos i referred to
the new female villain
as the villain waifu because we didn't
know her name
thankfully we now know that her name is
lady nagant
but i absolutely stand by my previous
statements
seriously why is this supposedly evil
woman
so freaking attractive i mean i realize
that this
probably isn't the most important
question of this chapter or
is it but damn just damn anyway
here at anime opera we are of course too
sophisticated to focus on such things as
waifus instead of highly advanced
analyses
and commentary so i will just get into
the story now
and in my spare time i will continue
writing a fanfic in which i get it got
into the mha world and suddenly miroko
and lady nagant both start battling for
my love eventually
i will realize that the only way to stop
this endless cycle of hero versus
villain violence is to just choose both
of them
and the world will be saved but yeah
where was i chapped right the chapter
okay so the chapter starts off with a
flashback to hawks and deku
discussing the mission to smoke out all
for one in shigaraki
hawk says that offer one must be
planning to capture deku alive
because they are yet to reach the point
where they can just steal one for all by
force
and with dr ujiko in custody and all of
his facilities shut down
it is unlikely that all for one would be
able to preserve deku's body
if he actually killed him so capturing
deku alive appears to be the only
feasible
option this probably explains why the
pro heroes agreed to have deku service
bait
because they're confident that he won't
be killed hawks then says that for most
of the skps from tartarus
capturing deku would be an impossible
task except for one
according to hawks if that woman is
involved
then it's a different story hawks
reveals that the woman he is referring
to
is his former senpai meaning his senior
and that the manhunt for her has been a
top priority for the heroes
in fact hawkes tells deku in no
uncertain terms that if he ever comes
face to face with
this woman he has to do everything he
can to run away
and then back in the present deku
confirms that the female villain who
just shot his secret transmission device
is the same woman that hawks was talking
about she is a former pro hero
affiliated with the hero public safety
commission
and her name is lady nagant whoa
so much information was just revealed in
only a few
panels this female villain that we've
all been wondering about
is not just some ordinary villain she is
a former pro hero who betrayed
the hero society she is also hawks's
former senpai
meaning that he probably worked with her
as part of the hero public safety
commission
and she is considered to be so strong
and so dangerous that even deku with the
power of one for all
must not attempt to fight her instead if
he ever comes across her he must run
away
as soon as possible by the way the name
lady nagant will make sense once we
discuss her quirk which is also revealed
in this chapter but more on that
later deku decides to take hawks's
advice and he attempts to run away from
lady nagant
but that is easier said than done and
now that deku's secret transmission
device was destroyed he can't contact
hawks and the others and tell them that
he is currently fighting
lady nagant so there is no guarantee
that some sort of backup
will arrive in time to help deku deku
attempts to retreat but that is
effectively blocked by lady nagan's
extremely accurate
sniping and at that point both
combatants are forced to acknowledge
each other's phenomenal abilities deku
recognizes that lady nagan's shooting is
on a whole other level
while lady nagant acknowledges that deku
is an absolute
mad lad in fact deku is the only person
who was able to deflect
two of her bullets which again
emphasizes that a regular hero stands
absolutely no
chance against this woman we then get to
see an old interview that pro hero snipe
did
some time ago in this interview snipe
who is known for his outstanding
shooting skills like that's his whole
thing
reveals that he is still the only second
best long distance sniper
in japan that is because his homing
quirk cannot compare to the shooting
skills
of lady nagant who by the way has an
insane range of 3 kilometers which is
like 5 times bigger than the range of
snipe
lady nagant possesses a quirk called
rifle
and with this quirk she is able to
produce a rifle from her right arm
as we saw in the previous chapter but
her quirk has another incredible ability
that we did not know about
until now she can actually mix and mold
her hair like
putty and then harden it in order to
create
specialized bullets bullets which she
can then fire through the rifle
her ability to completely control the
shape and structure of her bullets
allows her to produce results that the
other snipers cannot
even dream of that is why lady nagant is
known
as the human rifle and back when she was
a hero
all of the other pro heroes with long
range quirks were jealous
of her unbelievable skill and precision
back in the present deku is struggling
to deal with lady nagan's shooting
she has insanely accurate aim and she
can even shoot rapid-fire shots
so outrunning her seems to be an
impossible task
deku admits to himself that if he didn't
have danger since he would have been
defeated
a long time ago deku also concludes that
he won't be able to escape the villain's
range
at this rate right now he is only about
one kilometer away from her
and her range is three kilometers so
instead of running away deku decides to
get
closer to lady nagant after all snipers
are experts at long range combat
so if deku can get closer to her maybe
he can throw her
off and take away her biggest advantage
meanwhile
overhaul is still sitting on the rooftop
and listening to black
parade he calls out for the old man
again his old yakuza boss
and lady nagan tells him sure sure we'll
go see the old man
after this mission is over she wonders
if maybe she should have just left
overhaul behind back in tartarus
but she decided to bring him along
because she thought that he might be
useful
it is not revealed how exactly she was
expecting him to be useful
but i assume it's either related to his
quirk or to his knowledge
about the quirk cancelling bullets we
then get a flashback to the moment when
lady nagant and overhaul escaped from
tartarus
at one point she came face to face with
all for one
and he called her the traitor hero the
beautiful
lady nagant clearly all for one is a man
of culture as well
in fact all for one considers lady
nagant to be a league above
everyone else which is exactly how hawks
sees her as well
and because of this all for one asks
lady nagant to do him a very
important favor all for one foresaw that
deku will leave the ua
and start acting independently and he
asks lady nagant to capture deku
and bring him back to all for one at
first lady nagant has no interest in
this mission she just wants to get out
of tartarus and regain her freedom
but all for one reminds her that she has
already slaughtered
many of her fellow heroes but all of
that will be in vain
if she doesn't help him now according to
all for one
the fall of the pro-hero society that
she is hoping for
will never happen as long as deku lives
from this brief exchange it is clear
that lady nagant
really hates the pro-hero society
although it is not yet clear
why she feels that way but all for one
clearly knows how she feels
and he manages to convince her to make a
deal with him by straight up giving her
a new quirk
called airwalk airwalk is a quirk that
all for one had used before
and just like the name suggests it
allows its user to levitate
or walk on air suddenly back in the
present
lady nagant leaps into the air and vows
to carry on her mission to capture
deku and that is how this insane
chapter ends personally i loved this
chapter and i love that so many of our
questions about this new villain were
answered although to be fair
this chapter also raised a bunch of new
and very interesting questions about her
why did she betray the hero society and
why does she hate it
so much there has to be some deeply
personal reason
for this hatred and i bet her backstory
is going to be
really really interesting her name
appears to come from an old
russian rifle called the mossin nagant
this rifle was used by the russian army
against the japanese during the
russo-japanese war that took place
between 1904
and 1905 so maybe that's how horikoshi
came up with the name
i am definitely not an expert on rifles
so i have no idea how popular this rifle
is today
or how well known it is in japan but
it's an interesting choice of name
nonetheless now here are the big
questions that i have
after this chapter other than lady
nagan's backstory and why she betrayed
the hero society
i am also wondering what she wants with
overhaul
does she just want to use his quirk or
does she want to know more about the
quirk canceling bullets
or is there more to it than that and
while we're
on the topic of overhaul's quirk why
didn't all for one just steal it
back in tartarus all for one clearly
knew who overhaul was
and that means that he very likely knew
that overhaul's quirk could have healed
shigaraki
almost instantly so why wouldn't he just
steal the quirk
to heal shigaraki is this a plot
oversight by horikoshi
or is something else going on here also
could lady nagan to be connected to the
ua
traitor in some way i'm not sure for how
long she's actually been in tartarus
like has she been there for years
or was she only arrested recently but if
hypothetically her treason was only
discovered
in recent months then she could
theoretically be the ua trader herself
now no she's not a ua student or teacher
but through her role in the hero public
safety commission
she may have had access to sensitive
information about the ua
information that she might have passed
on to the villains for a price
i might be reaching here because i
really want the ua trader thing to
actually be resolved but you never know
finally and most importantly why is lady
nagant
so hot i can't quite pinpoint it but i
think it has a lot to do with her big
beautiful lats she is clearly in great
shape and who doesn't love a woman with
killer lats
but that is enough simping for today if
you enjoyed this video and you want to
see more videos like it
please leave that like to let me know it
really does help
and if you're new to anime outpour or
maybe watch our videos but you haven't
subscribed yet
do me a favor and make this the video
that you subscribe
and hit that notification bell to turn
on all
notifications you really have to go
through the trouble of subscribing
hitting that bell and then selecting the
option that says all
if you don't do that you're still going
to miss a ton of our videos even if you
are subscribed
it's just how youtube works you can also
hit me up on twitter
and instagram at anime uproar
a big thank you to all of our anime
opera patrons for making videos like
this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma red
haired raven
and av these guys are absolute
mad lads and disciples of lord twego
himself and i can't forget all of our
the one
tier patrons the ones who rise above all
other clans
including ingrata pate heffa algertol
dr cortman the toasted qi bang emperor
otaku spidey life canal tungsten targus
baked buddhist and you know finally
thank you also to our pro hero tier
patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh steelers
angel crews anatoly kazatsky cricket xp
rathu indiora very gucci alicia octor
bonnie parks hinokamian water joy and
garcia ted no ted isparky65 jessica
lafond metal mama
corey mcgowan fat boy games deadly saint
soul ray slice and dice and pillow if
you enjoy our videos and you feel that
they provide value for you
consider supporting us on patreon even a
single dollar will give you access to
our patron exclusive discord
and your name will appear in our videos
along with these
legendary people as always thank you
guys so much for watching
and until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you